talking about the Ford f-150 starting
today the latest generation of its
best-selling vehicle the monster truck
rolls off the line at their Kansas City
plant january sales for the f-series
reached its highest since 2004 and best
ford sales they're the best ford sales
ever bloomberg's matt miller standing by
with ford's president of the Americas
Matt hey Betty thanks very much Joe
Hinrichs joining us now from Kansas City
Joe thanks for joining us let me ask you
as you start a job one down there how
much production are you going to be
having of this f 150 because I know the
new truck has been difficult to keep on
the Lots yeah we're seeing such strong
demand for the truck we're so excited to
have these trucks rolling off the line
here in Kansas City when we get Kansas
City up to full line rate we'll be able
to produce over 700,000 f-150s between
dearborn and Kansas City too and we're
going to have all that kind of demand
from our customers I know the retail
sales have been incredibly strong fleet
sales maybe a little bit slower though
because the commercial guys and
construction guys they want the big
eight-foot boxes that are you going to
that you're going to start building down
there for the first time in in Kansas
City how do you expect that to improve
the revenue picture yeah Matt we're
right now we're building just pretty
much retail units that we launched the
the plant and get and build our stock in
our in our dealerships the fleet
deliveries are really gonna have to wait
till the second quarter there's strong
fleet demand but in March we're going to
see a fleet volume down again because
we're not building those those trucks
you talked about yet for the fleet
customers as we ramp up but we will
there's plenty demand for them as far as
the retail side I know consumers have
been really veering towards the high end
of the f-150 line they're buying the the
higher-end trims how does that impact
your bottom line well it's good for our
business clearly the SuperCrew that you
know the platinum and the King Ranch
versions are higher content higher price
points and that consumers are grabbing
them otha las it within less than 18
days right now is how long they're
lasting so it's good for our business
you know we have a significant market
share of the higher-end truck business
because our truck has such strong
residual values and and it has a lot of
content into the people like to have at
the higher end so we're excited about
that business and we want to give them
more trucks does the stronger dollar
help or hurt you in this situation John
Krafcik of true car has said that
American automakers are positioned well
with a stronger currency because they
can buy better materials for the
interior of the car is that does that
outweigh the competition disadvantages
that you have well you know generally
speaking with the strong dollar we get
lower commodity prices which are a big
deal to our business so we are seeing
good news to the business for the
combination of the stronger US dollar
with lower commodity prices as you
mentioned it does give an advantage to
those who import into this country which
largely affects the car side of the
business on the truck side of course
most is manufactured here so we are
seeing advantage with the strong of a
dollar on that side of the business do
you I mean do you see a disadvantage
with the lower oil prices because people
don't necessarily need to go out and buy
a more fuel-efficient truck which is
obviously the hallmark of the new f-150
well our data says customers still
consider fuel economy is one of their
chief reasons to buy and considerations
when they do buy a vehicle and as a LG
came out yesterday and said that Ford
has the best residual values of the the
domestic brands on the truck side
business that was largely driven by our
fuel economy improvements with the light
waiting so a lot of these things go hand
in hand and we think we have the right
combination let me ask you about the
jobs picture I know you're adding 909
Kansas City you're also bringing jobs
back from Mexico to make the bigger
lines of the f-series the f750 for
example I know starting in May is that
part of a trend this in sourcing of jobs
well we've seen that over time mat with
the agreements that we reached with the
UAW years ago to make us more
competitive we were able to make a
business case that do more work here and
the f 650 750 being built in Ohio
assembly plant later this year coming
from Mexico is a good example of that
even here at this plant we've insourced
work as a result of our competitiveness
so keeping that going going for will be
an important part of that equation of
creating jobs here in America alright
Joe thanks very much course creating
jobs here in America is your main focus
as president of the American